bon je vais pas vous refaire le coup de
la breaking news toutes les semaines
mais quand même là il doit philippe le
premier ministre il a dit un truc le
déconfinement ça n'est pas pour demain
matin
voilà donc je sais pas si vous avez
prévu un truc demain mais en tout cas
bloqué pas votre matinée pour tout ce
qui est activités de déconfinement ça va
pas être là vous pouvez continuer à
faire ou pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà on l'avait pas vu venir dit non on
n'est pas prêt de sortir je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez en vrai nom s'est dit
fin avril-début mai au mieux au mieux et
encore sap avec la foire à la saucisse
tout de suite ça va se faire de façon
crescendo donc prenons notre mal en
patience si vous voulez bien du coup
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un truc
est-ce que vous souvenez quand vous
étiez petits ou petites
est-ce qu'on vous disait à beyrouth va
jouer dehors c'est pas bon de rester à
l'intérieur comme ça tout le temps vous
souvenez quand vous disais ça vous
pensiez que c'était des mythos c'était
un truc pour se débarrasser de vous et
ben en fait non c'est vrai c'est pas bon
de rester à l'intérieur tout le temps
alors attention me faites pas dire ce
que j'ai pas dit il faut impérativement
respecter les règles de confinement on
reste à l'intérieur sauf en cas
d'absolue nécessité
et on fait en sorte que ce soit le mois
souvent impossible
ce oui est ce que je veux dire mais
quand même on va voir ensemble ce qui se
passe quand on reste tout le temps à
l'intérieur et surtout ce qu'il faut
faire pour pas que ce soit de mauvaise
pour notre santé alors il ya plusieurs
problèmes avec le profil mans il ya
plusieurs choses qui sont un très bonne
pour la santé
d'abord il ya ce qu'on appelle la
sédentarité c'est vers le fait de pas
bouger beaucoup ça c'est pas ouf
ensuite il ya le manque de soleil et le
manque d'exposition à la lumière du jour
après il ya la modification du rythme
habituel de vie et puis il ya évidemment
le l'isolément social le la diminution
des interactions et c'est donc tout ça
ça a des conséquences et on va tout de
suite voir ensemble et qu'elle les
troubles digestifs
oui alors c'est pas la peine de faire
vos précieuses 1 vous avez sûrement
remarqué qui se passe des choses à ce
niveau là depuis le début du film il se
passe même peut-être plusieurs choses
alors déjà le fait de rester enfermé
mais surtout le fait de rester sans
bouger ça diminue les mouvements de
notre intestin saint laurent un petit
peu par tout ce qui fait que excusez moi
d'appeler un chat un chat mais le caca
restent plus longtemps à l'intérieur
donc ils passent plus de temps dans le
colle aux essais dans le côlon que l'eau
et réabsorber donc il ya plus d'eau que
d'habitude qui est absorbée du coup le
caca devient sec il devient dur et il a
plus de mal à sortir
être constitué alors il ya une deuxième
possibilité qui est à peu près linverse
on va pas se mentir en ce moment vous
avez un petit peu de temps pour vous
donc peut-être que vous prenez temps de
cuisiner des bons plats des bons petits
trucs bien gras bien en sauce etc ou
alors n'ai pas du tout envie de vous
embêter la cuisine et du coup vous
bouffer n'importe quoi en tout cas vous
avez peut-être mais probablement
modifier notre régime alimentaire et du
coup bas votre intestin un petit peu du
mal à s'habituer et voilà en tout cas
d'une manière ou d'une autre les
changements ça se ressent ça se sent
peut-être même d'ailleurs et encore fait
pas ou sucré vous savez de quoi je parle
de toute façon que ce soit un problème
ou l'autre la solution est à peu près la
même à savoir manger équilibré manger
varié sur tout y compris des légumes y
compris des aliments riches en fibres
ça c'est une bonne chose ensuite buvez
buvez de l'eau régulièrement en quantité
suffisante et puis ayez une activité
physique régulière mais ça on va en
parler parce que c'est valable pour
plein d'autres choses
les troubles du sommeil clairement le
confinement ça joue sur le sommeil ça
c'est sûr déjà première chose vous
sortez - vous bougez - vous marchez -
vous ramez mans bref vous êtes moins
fatigués forcément vous allez un petit
peu plus de mal à dormir
et si en plus vous vivez pas trop bien
la période actuelle
ça aide pas forcément pour s'endormir le
soir mais il ya aussi un autre qui est
un petit peu plus physiologique notre
horloge biologique et notamment notre
rythme veille sommeil s'est déterminé
par un truc qu'on appelle le cycle
circadien qui dure 24 heures et qui est
régulée par la lumière du jour la
lumière naturelle du jour est là en ce
moment on est confiné on est à 80%
exposés à de la lumière artificielle et
ça c'est pas bon donc un truc à faire
c'est d'aller s'exposer
quand vous pouvez un petit peu mais
régulièrement dans la journée à la vraie
lumière du jour
ouvrez les fenêtres de temps en temps
allez vous exposer un petit peu au
soleil
on va y revenir un petit peu plus tard
mais ça aura aussi d'autres avantages
pas juste le soir une minute à 20 heures
pour aller applaudir passer un petit peu
de temps à la fenêtre passer un petit
peu de temps au soleil
ces hausses devraient pas être trop
désagréable au plus al'inverse le soir
quand vous allez vous coucher
fermez bien les volets parce que c'est
dans l'obscurité qu on sécrète la
mélatonine l'hormone du sommeil
bon après en réalité pour améliorer
votre sommeil les conseils c'est un
petit peu les mêmes qu'en temps normal
du coup ce que je vais faire c'est que
je vais vous renvoyer vers ma vidéo que
j'ai fait il ya quelques temps sur le
sujet je vous mets le lien dans la
description les problèmes liés à
l'inactivité
oui le fait de pas bouger beaucoup ça ne
fait pas que rendre votre intestin
feignants
ça fait pas que vous compliquer la tâche
pour vous endormir sa aussi plein
d'autres conséquences
ça a des conséquences au niveau de vos
muscles par exemple c'est logique vous
les solliciter moi vous bougez - vous
mais moi donc il travaille moi du coup
il fonde et ça c'est un petit peu
embêtant là je vous parle pas de votre
sauveur baudille qu'on soit bien clair
là je vous parle de vos muscles profonds
ceux qui sont chargés de maintenir votre
grande carcasse d'aplomb et quand il
fonde tout ça ça se tient moins bien et
ça peut occasionner des problèmes de dos
des problèmes au niveau des cervicales
ça peut occasionner problèmes au niveau
des articulations et c'est donc pas top
donc petit conseil qui va valoir aussi
pour plein d'autres choses globalement
garder une activité physique régulière
tous les jours fait un petit peu de
sport pas forcément des trucs de ouf
enfin c'est pas la peine de faire du
fitness c'est pas la peine de faire des
trucs de taré mais juste solliciter vos
muscles et notamment aux muscles
profonds vos muscles posturaux ça va
vous sauver la mise
je vais vous mettre quelques petits
exercices dans la description de la
vidéo
faites vous plaisir en dès lors des
petits exercices physiques ce sera
vraiment bien que vous fassiez tous les
jours ce qui est important aussi c'est
ne pas rester allongés ou assis tout le
temps en tout cas pas de façon prolongée
régulièrement levez vous faites juste
quelques pas dans l'appartement juste
histoire de faire circuler un petit peu
le sens la circulation sanguine c'est
pareil quand vous faites rien elle se
fait au ralenti
vos organes vos muscles sont moins bien
oxygénée et puis il ya un autre problème
un autre risque on va dire ce qu'on
appelle le risque thrombo embolique
votre sens quand ils circulent moins
il a tendance à potentiellement faire
des petits cailloux c'est petit caillou
ça peut aller bouchée des toutes petites
veines ou d'un petit peu plus grosse ou
des artères d'être un petit peu plus
embêtant ça peut être par exemple des
phlébites 1-1 moquer assez rigolo mais
vous n'avez pas envie d'avoir ça ça peut
être des trucs un peu plus embêtant j'ai
pas envie de faire flipper avec ça mais
en tout cas des exercices physiques
régulièrement et puis ne restez pas à
votre est tout le temps sur le canapé
que les pieds sur la table basse remuez
vous un petit peu régulièrement ça ça
devrait bien se passer
les troubles liés au manque de soleil on
a vu de la lumière du jour c'était
important pour bien caler son sommeil
mais le soleil il sert aussi pour plein
d'autres choses
les uvb par exemple ils nous aident à
synthétiser de la vitamine b qui
renforce nos muscles et nozoe qui
protège certains neurones au niveau de
notre cerveau donc c'est graal pas mal
surtout justin on s'expose au soleil
et donc on a vu que la lumière du jour
donc le soleil ça rythme la production
de mélatonine qui est pas seulement
responsable de nous aider à bien dormir
mais qui a aussi un rôle dans le système
immunitaire
la production de spermatozoïdes le cycle
menstruel
voilà l ulcère à plein de choses donc la
nuit du noir la journée du soleil
d'avril à toulouse
et puis pour rester dans la série des
petites substance qui font du bien
le soleil ça stimule aussi la sécrétion
de sérotonine pas si vous connaissez la
sérotonine c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'hormone du bonheur
c'est probablement ce qui fait que
l'hiver quand il ya moins de soleil on
met un petit peu des prix même sa
fameuse dépression ou déprime
saisonnière
donc si en plus ça fait du bien et on
sait aussi qu'il ya un certain nombre de
maladies de peau dont les symptômes ont
plutôt tendance à se calmer au soleil
donc comme on a vidé que vous pouvez
aller vous caler quelques minutes au
soleil à la fenêtre au calme je me suis
à peu près sûr que vous m'avez pas
attendu par contre on est d'accord à la
fenêtre
à l'intérieur on reste chez soi le
soleil sera encore là la fin du
confinement
on aura encore le temps d'en profiter la
pollution intérieure alors une bonne
nouvelle je sais pas si vous avez vu
depuis qu'on est tous confinés
l'air est re devenu dur l'eau est
redevenue clair les animaux sont hyper
contents ils se baladent partout c'est
génial voilà donc est ce que on avait
vraiment besoin de ça pour être sûr
qu'on est l'espèce la plus nuisible de
la planète n'ont sûrement pas mais voilà
maintenant on est fixé par contre au
delà de ça le revers de la médaille
c'est que hockey à l'extérieur
maintenant qu'on n'y est plus c'est plus
clean par contre maintenant qu'on passe
tout le temps à l'intérieur c'est à
l'intérieur que c'est polluent la
pollution de l'air intérieur c'est comme
ça que ça s'appelle c'est un truc qu'on
connaît bien et c'est proportionnel au
temps qu'on passe à l'intérieur vous
imaginez un petit plomb alors qu'est ce
qui pollue l'air à l'intérieur
d'abord première chose les produits
d'entretien
en ce moment on est beaucoup à
l'intérieur on salit beaucoup on a un
petit peu que ça à faire donc ça y va ça
récurrent on fait le ménage on fait le
ménage on fait le ménage
donc on utilise plus de produits
d'entretien d'habitude donc on peut lui
plus notre air intérieur
un autre truc qui polluent pas mal tout
ce qui est des autorisant même les
bougies parfumées et c'est ça autant
dire que ça y va aussi pour des raisons
qu'on a évoqué au tout début de la vidéo
puis aussi tout ce qui est fumée de
cuisson des aliments fumée de clopes de
tabac et puis les acariens les acariens
ils nourrissent notamment de nos petites
peaux mortes qui tombe comme en ce
moment on est tout le temps à
l'intérieur on n'en répond encore plus
que d'habitude donc ils ont plein à
bouffer donc qu'ils sont là ils sont
bien le problème c'est tout ça avant
tout d'un moment ça a des répercussions
sur nos poumons sur notre respiration et
on n'a pas besoin de ça en ce moment
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire déjà
première chose on respecte les doses des
produits d'entretien idéalement achetez
vendez pas trop vénère mais déjà si vous
pouvez respecter ce qui est marqué sur
l'étiquette en termes de dosage
ces parades ensuite vous passez
l'aspirateur pour les acariens et puis
c'est pas la peine d'aller récurer avec
des litres et des litres de produits
chimiques toute la journée
nettoyez de temps en temps mais c'est
pas la peine allez-y mollo sur les
désodorisants allez-y mollo sur les
bougies parfumées et a par contre aérer
le plus souvent possible
il fait beau l'air à l'extérieur il est
moins pollué que d'habitude donc laisser
les fenêtres ouvertes le plus possible
ça va permettre d'évacuer un petit peu
toutes les saloperies les conséquences
psychologiques
déjà il ya tout ce qui est sic
automatique on a parlé tout à l'heure
des maladies possède genre de choses qui
se déclenchent volontiers dans des
périodes de stress mais il ya d'autres
choses aussi le stress ça peut par
exemple perturbé le cycle menstruel vais
peut-être remarqué jeu si vous possédez
un vagin que c'est moins réguliers en ce
moment voilà le stress ça peut provoquer
plein de choses comme ça ça peut
provoquer aussi
lang irrépressible de se laisser pousser
la moustache ou de se faire une frange
par exemple ou les deux et puis il ya
des trucs un petit peu plus profond un
petit peu plus lourd que ça il ya plein
de raisons pour lesquelles on peut ne
pas supporter la période actuelle
la solitude déjà pour les gens qui sont
confinés solo par exemple la peur de la
maladie pour soi ou pour ses proches
il ya aussi des gens qui de base sont un
petit peu anxieux facilement angoissé
déprimé voire dépressif
bon bah évidemment la période actuelle
ça n'arrange rien je vous ai déjà donné
un certain nombre de conseils pour
essayer de supporter au mieux le
confinement dans une vidéo précédente je
vais vous remettre le lien dans la
description de la vidéo je vous remets
aussi des documents qui parle un petit
peu de ça des conseils des vidéos etc
mais quand même il ya deux trois trucs
qu'on peut redire déjà n'y a pas un truc
qui marche pour tout le monde pour
supporter ce qui se passe un petit peu
en ce moment ça dépend de notre
personnalité notre vécu de nos
difficultés par rapport à ça
par contre il ya des grands principes
quand même qu'on peut rappeler et qui
font toujours du bien
d'abord je crois que ça peut faire du
bien de considérer qu'on vit une période
un petit peu hors du temps le
confinement il est repoussé de 15 jours
en 15 jours les informations on les a
vraiment au fur et à mesure il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur l'avenir
on sait pas quand ce sera on ne sait pas
à quoi ça va ressembler donc c'est
vraiment le moment de vivre dans
l'instant présent et ne pas chercher à
aller voir forcément beaucoup plus loin
que la journée il faut vivre au jour le
jour
carpediem un petit peu c'est donc un
jour après l'autre on se concentre sur
le seul truc qu'on maîtrise à peu près
c'est à dire ici maintenant et
aujourd'hui demain on verra demain
ensuite pour pas déglingué notre horloge
biologique et pour pas à perdre tous nos
repères c'est bien de garder un rythme
c'est bien de garder un petit peu des
rituels se coucher et se lever pas trop
tard manger à peu près aux heures
habituelles se laver
vous plaît par pitié s'habiller on n'est
pas obligé de sortir les smokings et les
robes de soirée mais ça peut être pas
mal de faire un petit peu attention à
son apparence ne serait ce que pour se
plaire à soi c'est important de se
plaire à soi pour l'estimé de soi à ce
moment où s'écoulent et qu'il faut faire
des trucs en plus du télétravail pour se
quitter les rails je veux dire être
actif physiquement comme on l'a vu mais
aussi intellectuellement c'est vital en
ce moment attention c'est très très bien
si vous profitez du confinement pour
créer des choses pour vous cultivez etc
mais qu'on soit bien clair on va pas
tous écrire le prochain concours en un
mois l'a donc vous collait pas la
pression faites ce que vous avez envie
faire fait des trucs mais à votre
échelle à votre niveau et ça m'amène
directement à mon dernier conseil faites
vous plaisir
on vit au jour le jour on a dit il ya
des trucs dont on est obligé de les
faire pour le reste pour meubler son
confinement
laissez vous guider par les trucs qui
vous font envie les trucs qui vous font
plaisir une période comme en ce moment
on en vivra peut-être plus jamais
peut-être que si mais pas sûr c'est
vraiment le moment de se faire plein on
n'a que ça à faire faisons-nous du bien
voilà épi évidemment le lien social
prenez des nouvelles de vos amis donner
des nouvelles à vos amis reprenait
contact peut-être avec des gens avec qui
vous n'avez pas discuté depuis longtemps
discuté avec vos potes échanges et
surtout si vous êtes confiné solo
évidemment est-il besoin de préciser que
c'est hyper important pour vous et pour
les autres aussi
si malgré tout tout ça ça vous n'êtes
pas aller mieux il ya un numéro vert
auquel vous pouvez avoir un soutien
psychologique c'est le 0 800 130 000
n'hésitez pas à bhl l'alcool bah oui
vous croyez que vous avez vu comment
c'est l'apéro plus en plus tôt bon en
vrai il ya plein de cas de figure très
différents avec l'alcool
donc on va rester hyper factuel d'abord
voir seul sait jamais une bonne idée
voir parce que on va pas bien boire pour
que le temps passe plus vite c'est pas
top non plus pour ça je vous renvoie la
vidéo
effet sur le sujet dont je vais vous
remettre le lien aussi je vous reviens
aussi le lien pour faire le test qui va
nous permettre d'évaluer votre
consommation d'alcool mais je vais aussi
vous donner quelques chiffres
ces chiffres ont été établis par des
experts et ils définissent ce qu'on
appelle une consommation raisonnable
d'alcool alors une consommation rasades
d'alcool ça veut dire celle qui permet
de diminuer au maximum les risques pour
la santé et les risques d'addiction tout
cas de les rendre acceptables sans pour
autant se priver complètement de boire
de l'alcool une consommation raisonnable
d'alcool c maximum dix verres de
boissons alcoolisées par semaine mais
pas plus de deux par jour et pas tous
les jours et on parle de verre comme ils
sont dosés dans les bars donc c'est
précis voilà maintenant vous savez les
risques de violences parfois le danger
il vient de la personne ou des personnes
avec qui on est confiné donc comme
d'habitude je vous remets toutes les
informations sur les conduites à tenir
en cas de violence conjugale ou de
violences sur enfants et faut savoir que
maintenant
depuis pas longtemps là on peut aussi
signaler qu'on est en danger en envoyant
juste un sms au 114 habituellement 114
c'est le numéro d'urgence pour les
sourds et les malentendants
là il a été étendu aux violences
intrafamiliales c'est vrai que c'est
plus facile d'envoyer discrètement un
sms gilles faut juste envoyer un sms
soit 114 et puis après l'opérateur
téléphonique qui se charge de
transmettre aux coordonnées aux
autorités dernière chose parmi les gens
qui sont confinés
il ya des gens qui de base ont des
problèmes de santé des maladies
chroniques et des addictions plein de
trucs le suivi pour ces personnes là
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
d'habitude mais déjà il ya les
téléconsultations donc si c'est votre
cas
c'est important de garder un suivi avec
votre médecin votre psy fin avec la
personne qui vous suis habitude c'est
important de paron couple
mon contact et puis pour les autres
c'est encore plus important en ce moment
que d'habitude de prendre des nouvelles
de témoigner du soutien et de rendre
service si on veut d'ailleurs en ce
moment il ya plein de gens qui ont
besoin qu'on leur rende service
globalement clairement c'est la
meilleure façon d'occuper son
confinement et de mieux vivre soi-même
en plus donc tout le monde est gagnant
dans cette histoire française ici vous
pouvez rendre service aux gens fêtent le
voilà encore une fois un bon courage à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont
confinés continuer à bien respecter les
consignes à la fin c'est sûr on va
gagner immense merci
évidemment à toutes celles et à tous
ceux qui continuent à bosser pour qu'on
puisse continuer à vivre à peu près
normalement pour sauver notre peau ou
pour faire en sorte qu'on sorte de cette
période le plus rapidement possible
merci merci merci
btc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo qui parlera peut-être d'autres
choses d'ailleurs dit moi dans les
commentaires si vous préférez moi je ne
sais plus j'avoue d'ici là prenez soin
de vous et prenez soin des autres
restez chez vous mettez vous bien et
surtout portez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]